pour
[Musique]
la déportation à l'envers liliane vetter
replonge dans les événements qui ont
marqué sa vie
[Musique]
paper né au nouveau brunswick en 1922
liliane est adoptée par les acadiens
vivant aux etats unis c'est là que
l'acadienne américaine pas sa vie
jusqu'à ce voyage en louisiane à l'âge
de 71 ans où elle cherche des petits pas
son nom de naissance de jean de luz sera
mal dit pourquoi aller mieux vaut pas au
congrès mondial acadien généra je savais
pas intrigué liliane écrit pour obtenir
des informations sur ce premier congrès
mondial acadien
j'avais peur expectations de trouver fr
dès leur arrivée au nouveau brunswick
armé de son baptistère et de
renseignements très limité liliane vais
te cherche sa famille biologique à
barachois shediac et richibouctou
village où elle rencontre sa marraine
mais sa plus grande surprise l'attend à
l'hôtel un message de sa soeur inconnu
jette à la forêt elle m'a dit oui à
l'été massa où elle avait et on sort je
pouvais hors amm et accès
le lendemain les petits pas attendent
avec émotion l'arrivée de leur soeur
perdu avec laquelle le roi entre temps
[Musique]
[Rires]
ce miracle pouces liliane vetter a
quitté l'arizona pour s'installer en
acadie tous les jours mon frère voilà
visite et m'a dit mettez moi c'est lui à
mes joies yeuse sitôt le 7 mai lors
c'est un miracle a toujours adoré sa
famille et pour la famille pour lui a
toujours été quelque chose de très
important avoir été adopté et puis pour
lui d'avoir trouvé sa façade à 97 ans
seul survivant de sa fratrie les lianes
profite encore au maximum des sorties et
des rencontres avec ses nièces et neveux
choqué le plus pauvre chez qu'on a une
une âme et diokoul de données liliane
vit maintenant au foyer avec sa belle
soeur lina petit pas ils sont tous les
deux d'un même foyer
ça fait qu'on peut vraiment profiter de
prendre du temps avec elle parce qu'on
vient visiter ma mère me souviens
souvent maintenant et bien de venir nous
voir dans la chambre des enfants
les créateurs du premier congrès mondial
acadien s'était donné comme mission de
réunir les familles acadiennes
au delà des festivités cette
réunification se vit au quotidien depuis
25 ans chez les petits pas
[Musique]
j'aime bien mal est de dire merci parce
qu'ils auront quel bac tu mets ma
famille de l'ouest trois niveaux un pin
à pin et de ce big merci beaucoup
[Musique]